this week on
brian ross investigates the race for the
vaccine
what you need to know when will it be
approved
who will get it first will it be safe
why the president claims
he made it all possible i can say that
our request for emergency use
authorization
for our coveted vaccine is now in the
fda trends we're joined by dr william
shaftner from vanderbilt university
and adviser to the fda on the kovit 19
vaccine approval process plus could it
get any more embarrassing
or outrageous the president's legal team
strikes out again and again
in court this is not a this is not a
fraud case
i heard somebody else say something tell
me why that's not here to say come on
now
once widely admired rudolph giuliani
laughed out of court
and in the court of public opinion at
one point
rudy's hair dye
actually started dripping down his face
this is
real we didn't do this take a look at
them we're frustrated with
what we keep reading will the president
and his lawyers pay a price for their
legal antics
we're joined by former giuliani ken
friedman
law and crime investigative reporter
adam classville
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
the president's followers turned on
tucker carlson and fox news
see if you agree with the findings of
the editors of mediaite
but she never sent us any evidence
despite a lot of requests polite
requests
not a page when we kept pressing she got
angry and told us to stop contacting her
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always tonight
by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the promising
news of a potential
covert 19 vaccine actually three of them
all coming though as we face perhaps the
darkest days of this pandemic
with one american on average dying every
minute
from covet 19 rhonda
that's right brian and it's a terrible
toll and to get some perspective
when the pandemic was declared a
national emergency
last march only less than 50 people had
died
this has all happened since then and
with thanksgiving and the holidays on
the way
there's real concerns about what lies
ahead
but perhaps ronda much to be thankful
for with the development of these
vaccines
here's how the people at pfizer
announced the good news from their
company
our vaccine candidate has demonstrated
efficacy of
95 percent against covet 19 with
no serious safety concerns observed to
date
based on current projections we expect
to produce globally up to
50 million doses in 2020 and
up to 1.3 billion doses by the end of
2021.
we're joined now by dr william shaffner
of vanderbilt university a regular
program who's given us such great
insight dr schaffner as the fda prepares
to take a look at these vaccines
what are they really looking for is
there anything that hold this up
i don't think there'll be much to hold
us up ryan they'll be looking
at how well does this vaccine work does
it work in all
age groups studied children haven't been
studied yet
that comes next and they will also be
paying a lot of attention
to safety are there any serious
adverse reactions associated with this
vaccine
this vaccine does make your arm sore it
hurts and it makes some people feel
punk the next day i mean to the point of
actually having to take a day off
so it's what we call reactogenic but so
far
as far as we know no major safety issues
and that's very reassuring
have you been surprised at the reports
of 90
plus efficacy for each of these three
products
i've been blown away i've been very
excited about that
we would have been delighted at 70
percent effectiveness
but over 90 percent and now three
vaccines
studied in three separate large trials
they all reinforce each other i think
this effectiveness
is very solid the other thing is
as you said we're in a long dark tunnel
but these are three bright lights
at the end of that tunnel we still have
a long way to go
but all of a sudden we're getting
optimistic
indeed a question for you dr schaffner
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
dr schaffner the fda says it's going to
start meeting on december 10th
to do the final evaluations to get this
underway
but there are reports that the uk is
going to start administering
this vaccine starting next week december
1st
what's the what's the difference there
well that's there
we're here they have a somewhat
different schedule
our fda will look at this very carefully
and they have an external group of
experts
that will take these data apart and put
them together
that's a transparent meeting if you're
interested you can tune in
and then after they approve it give it
the emergency use authorization
it will go to the cdc's advisory
committee on immunization practices
and they'll approve it i think and then
give us their prioritization scheme
as to who should go first second and
third that's
also a group of experts that will look
very carefully at the data
i think we'll all be reassured and
healthcare workers will go first and
then the rest of us
in due course will get in line
dr schaffner the fda group is said to be
meeting december 10th why couldn't it be
any sooner than that what's the uh
hold up well first of all it's a large
amount of material that comes in from
the
from the company the agency itself
has to review it it then has to go
to a committee this external committee
and you want
each of those external experts they're
tough
to really look at the data and have a
chance to
really understand it and ask questions
of the manufacturer
and then they come together at this
meeting
i think the timing is okay you know
we've gone
very fast but we don't want this to be
rushed
this is routine practice very rigorous
and frankly that's the way we all want
it i think we'll start vaccinating
by the end of december
that's great news but doctor how about
for your holidays this thanksgiving and
the holidays at the end of
the year what are you going to do uh
they will be holidays in spirit
but not very much in person our dining
room table will be very small
just the immediate family we're not
getting everyone together
we're being very careful sheltering at
home
giving thanks but not giving the virus
once again dr william shaftner thank you
so much you've been with us ever since
we began reporting on this
nine months ago it's been a long nine
months and it's great to see you say
light at the end of the tunnel have a
very good thanksgiving thanks
the same to you and to same toronto
thank you
you bet all right coming up next what
even
trump's own supporters call a national
embarrassment
a close-up look at the trump legal team
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime
trial network
it's being called pathetic a national
embarrassment
even conservative radio talk show host
rush limbaugh is critical
of the trump legal team led by rudy
giuliani
after widespread public claims of
widespread
national fraud the lawyers have gone to
court and told judges that
there is no fraud this is not a fraud
case
we are not alleging this possibility
but the uh we're not alleging that
anyone was feeling the election
to use well let me ask you are you
arguing then that strict scrutiny should
apply here
no the normal scrutiny should play with
if if we had alleged fraud
yes but this is not a this is not a
fraud case
joining us now is ken friedman a former
press secretary for rudolph giuliani
when he ran for mayor in new york city
and adam klausville the senior
investigative correspondent
at law and crime news and adam let me
start with you thank you both for being
here
what's the record so far of the giuliani
legal team on behalf of president trump
well so far they're losing the majority
of their cases but
more than that they are basically
demolishing
the talking points that they keep
putting out there in the public sphere
now we have to remember they keep
alleging when they're in front of
the cameras they talk about this massive
fraud that they go in front of a judge
and they say and this is a direct quote
from rudy giuliani this is not a fraud
case
another trump attorney corey langhofer
used those exact words
and other trump attorneys have used
variations of those words
so they undercut their own case what
evidence at
all have they presented anything that
comes close to their
exaggerated claims well we can point to
one
stack of quote unquote evidence that was
tried that they tried to introduce in
arizona
and it was a stack of affidavits that
were filled out by electronic form
letter
now these affidavits some of them they
admitted contained
lies and in their words spam
uh one of and those were the ones that
they could
confirm were false affidavits under oath
they did not submit the ones that they
could not
prove were false affidavits they tried
to run those by the judge who said well
you're just showing me things that you
can't disprove that doesn't make them
reliable so uh rudolph giuliani and his
team
really being laughed out of court and
laughed at in the court of public
opinion
ken freeman what happened to rudy
giuliani there was a time when he was
so highly regarded america's mayor a top
federal prosecutor
he met he met and went to work for
donald trump that's what happened you
know donald trump
corrupts everyone around him and uh
even even somebody who was formerly
incorruptable we thought like like rudy
giuliani
you know the question that remains is
why
why why is rudy representing donald
trump
in this case he's never practiced
election law he hasn't
he hasn't been in a in a courtroom in in
30 years
certainly there was somebody more
qualified
to to handle this this case
um you know is it because he trusts rudy
or because as as rudy said
about a year ago he's got insurance on
trump
um and if he has insurance what what is
that insurance it must be pretty good
insurance i wish i had such good
insurance
tell you the truth um
do you recognize this man from the man
you once knew
with the hair dye coming down the side
of his face and sweating
and bumbling and mispronouncing things
yeah see i'm not sure that wasn't
brain fluid that was leaking from this
ear to tell you the truth
um no of course not i i worked for a
very
smart competent ambitious
um
and we all achieved something historic
that i've been proud of for many years
but
every time rudy opens his mouth it
diminishes my my resume and the resume
of so many of my colleagues
you know he says he doesn't care about
his legacy because he'll be dead but i i
care about my legacy
yeah and adam class so let me ask you
the latest news over the weekend was
that
one of the legal team members sidney
powell has now been disavowed by the
white house
doesn't represent anybody what happened
there with sidney powell and her
wild conspiracy allegations
well what happened is a continuation of
what we've been seeing with trump's
legal team which is
attrition uh we have seen that
the major law firms uh have pulled out
uh porter wright in pennsylvania
uh there has and with sydney powell we
had that press conference where she
spouted wild conspiracy theories and it
got to be too much for
a legal team that has traded
on wild conspiracy theories now i should
make clear we don't know
precisely what led to that remarkable
statement where
uh the trump campaign is now uh
claiming that someone who shared the
stage with the rest of their legal team
is
not in fact associated with their legal
team
but one can put it in context and say
that the attorneys and law firms keep
pulling out and uh and the
uh conspiracy theories that she spouted
on that stage
uh have led to a lot widespread derision
that
just may not have looked good for team
trump
i don't know in fact one white house
insider said that she's too crazy even
for donald trump
uh ken friedman is uh rudy giuliani
going crazy here
what's he doing really what do you think
a dash for relevance his last shot
yes i think there's a lot of desperation
uh
you know that that that that results in
that flop sweat
he knows he's just flailing around and
that they have no evidence if they had
evidence they would they would produce
it in court
uh just to follow on what adam said
earlier
you know rudy said it's not a fraud case
if it's not a fraud case or these are
not fraud cases what are they
what are they but legally i would put
that to you know an attorney on the
uh representing him if they're not
arguing fraud whether they argue they
are agreeing
that maduro and and chavez are behind it
you know he's dead and he and he's dead
can't even follow it now
and adam finally how long can this drag
out at this point can it go
up till uh first of next month
well you know i've heard one uh legal
analyst or red red legal analyst say
that
some of these lawsuits are tweets with
filing fees
and so long as they don't uh give up the
ghosts
it's possible to drag something out but
in terms of actually accomplish what
they set out to accomplish
i think we'll find out soon whether or
not the supreme court will even listen
to the case they brought
an appeal to the third circuit and once
that actually landed
to an appellate court they're not even
fighting the case they're fighting for a
chance to amend their complaint
so what we're seeing is flailing and
desperation as as long as they want to
drag this out
absolutely well good reporting adam
thank you so much for joining us
adam clansfield from the law and crime
news and ken freeman former press
secretary for rudolph giuliani and now a
media consultant
thank you both for being here today
thanks for having us
thank you for having
up us this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the editors of
mediaite with what they have to say
about tucker carlson and fox news
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite and we're joined by
the
editor-in-chief of meteorite aid
mclaughlin mediaite
what's like the law and crime tower
network is all part of the dan abrams
media empire
and aiden tucker carlson has often been
one of your losers but this week's
he's a winner let's watch why
so we invited sydney powell on the show
we would have given her the whole hour
we would have given her the entire week
actually and listened quietly the whole
time
at rap detention that's a big story
but she never sent us any evidence
despite a lot of requests polite
requests not a page
when we kept pressing she got angry and
told us to stop contacting her
when we checked with others around the
trump campaign people in positions of
authority they told us
powell has never given them any evidence
either nor did she provide
any today at the press conference
there he is aiden taking on the sydney
powell a trump lawyer at the time no
longer
working for trump disavowed by the white
house
yeah that's right so tucker carlson as
you know has been loser in the loser
side of the column for us
frequently he actually was last week
when he pushed
uh some of president donald trump's
claims that dead voters had voted in the
uh 2020 election he had issued a
correction shortly afterwards because
one of the voters turned out to be alive
uh he sort of redeemed himself a little
bit last week
because he had this segment about sydney
powell
who was one of trump's lawyers who was
floating this pretty vast conspiracy
theory
about venezuelan voting machines that
were being used by communists and george
soros
to steal the election from donald trump
it was pretty wacky stuff and when
tucker carlson reached out to sydney
powell
to ask that she provide some evidence or
come on the show to discuss the
theory uh she actually got angry and and
apparently they had a little uh argument
and uh then he reported to his viewers
that that's what happened
which is commendable because i think on
tucker carlson's show and particularly
on fox news prime time
you don't really hear much skepticism
about these wild theories that team
trump is pushing
so for him to come out and say that
cindy powell is simply not providing
evidence of these
claims uh was you know commendable and
it was actually prescient because she
got booted from the trump legal team
by sunday of this week
has he paid a price in ratings though
for taking on the trump lawyer
well you know it's funny actually he got
beaten in the demo
ratings on friday night by anderson
cooper which as you know brian cnn
beating out fox news in prime time is a
huge deal
so he may have suffered a little bit of
a a dip in the ratings as fox news
is generally uh just because a lot of
their audience wants to hear
them report that donald trump has
actually won this election which we know
is false
uh i i would caution that i think that's
all very
temporary fox news the conservative
network is going to be for a long time
i wouldn't call this sort of an exodus
of viewership
from the network so much as just you
know people whose candidate has lost or
tuning out a little bit
now let's turn to this week's loser
geraldo rivera on fox news
and let's watch the video how he earned
his stripes so to say
i had an idea uh you know when with the
world so divided and everybody you know
telling him he's got to give up and
time to leave and the time to transition
and all the rest of it
why not name the black scene the trump
you know make it like have you gotten
your trump yet
no it'd be a nice gesture to him and
years from now it would become just a
kind of a generic game
have you i got you trump yet oh yeah i
got my trump i'm fine
you know i wish we could honor him in
that way
even his co-panelists were giggling
about that one aidan
i think if you managed to make the fox
and friends hosts
giggle with your sick of nc you've
probably gone a step too far
so this was geraldo's idea you know he
earlier
he's been a friend of the president for
a long time uh and his pitch here was
that
the only way to bring this country
together after it's been torn apart by
an election
that the president is claiming that he
won and it was stolen from him by
democrats
is to name the vaccine after trump i i
think everyone's aware of how insane
that is
and also the fact that we have to sort
of coddle the ego
of the president of the united states
because he didn't win re-election
by naming a vaccine after him for a
pandemic that
you know he's arguably contributing to
by just
caring so little about the granovirus
and having sort of conflicting messaging
on it
is a little bit absurd and uh that's
pretty much why we we named geraldo the
uh the loser to
that week and certainly was and
you wonder what he was thinking yeah i
mean
it's something it's the kind of thing
that he's pushed before although he has
this personal relationship with trump
that i find i think he finds hard
to separate from a professional
relationship or from just looking at
trump in sort of a journalistic fashion
and saying
you know the president united states
does not need to be rewarded
for losing an election so that he goes
quietly and sort of
reunites the country all right
all right and thank you very much to
thank all of you for watching have a
safe and happy thanksgiving we'll see
you
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you